y agosto de 2020 alexéi navalni se
enfermó con un fuerte dolor de estómago
en un vuelo desde siberia la principal
figura de la oposición rusa fue sacado a
toda prisa del avión y posteriormente
trasladado entre la vida y la muerte a
berlín en alemania los médicos
encontraron en sus análisis rastros de
no que una sustancia química
potencialmente letal un envenenamiento
que provocó indignación en todo el mundo
al escena vall ni se recuperó y siguió
desafiando al kremlin si esa gente ahora
me guarda rencor porque no pudieron
matarme y yo sobreviví y ahora me
amenazan con meterme en la cárcel
durante años alexéi navalni ha estado en
el punto de mira del gobierno ruso este
abogado moscovita ha hecho de la lucha
contra la corrupción su caballo de
batalla fue en 2011 durante las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales que
siguieron a las elecciones legislativas
de ese mismo año cuando nava el cni
adquirió realmente notoriedad luego tuvo
que hacer malabares con varias condenas
suspendidas primero por malversación de
fondos que le impidieron presentarse a
las elecciones presidenciales de 2018 a
su regreso a rusia a principios de 2021
fue arrestado luego fue trasladado tras
un juicio rápido a una colonia penal por
haber violado el control judicial
durante su anterior condena
no son los dueños de nuestro país y
nunca lo serán y un gran número de
personas decenas de millones de personas
están de acuerdo conmigo
hoy alexéi navalni está cumpliendo una
condena de dos años y medio en prisión y
este martes fue sentenciado a nueve años
adicionales acusado de fraude y desacato
desde su celda no ha dudado en denunciar
la intervención rusa en ucrania y ha
llamado a los ciudadanos a protestar en
las calles contra la guerra